deadite Fusion wood shipper Mayhem and
one bad mother let's dive into Evil Dead
Rises finale and dissect some of its
biggest moments hey guess what spoilers
ahead
before delving into Evil Dead Rises
bloody climax let's talk quickly about
this film's version of the Necronomicon
since it Bears an interesting connection
to the franchise's history and has some
unique variations both in design and
execution in an interview with Empire
magazine director Lee Cronin talked
about how this film's Necronomicon was
inspired by something he saw in Army of
Darkness when Cronin first started
meeting with Sam Raimi about Evil Dead
rise he brought up the three
necronomicons shown in the film and said
that he wanted to utilize one of them
for his own entry Cronin said it gave me
that platform to nudge things forward
and also to Showcase that we live in a
world where there is more than one copy
of the Necronomicon those books may all
have slightly different personalities
thus this book is a part of franchise
lore and comes with its own brand of
evil its design is absolutely chilling
featuring serious varicose veins on the
cover and a pair of sharp teeth that
keep it locked until the reader offers
up some blood there's actually no text
in the book so the usual method of
reading from it to unleash the spirit
doesn't apply here instead the book in
Evil Dead rise utilizes an interesting
concept of a recording of a priest
reading cryptic text as the Catalyst to
let its evil entity free Evil Dead rise
acts as a new chapter for the franchise
so it's only fitting for it to have its
own Book of the Dead
for most of the film The Family only
deals with one deadite trying to torture
and kill them the family matriarch Ellie
however that changes when Beth discovers
that Bridget has become a monster as
well Bridget's transformation traces
back to when Ali tries to give Bridget a
gnarly tattoo and infects her with some
of her own blood she drills the tattoo
gun into Bridget's cheek giving her a
nasty gash that's not going to heal
easily by the time we see the cut again
it has turned a sickly black and starts
to sprout dark veins all over Bridget's
face never a good sign as it spreads
like a skin infection the entity's power
begins to consume Bridget until she's
fully possessed and starts vomiting up
worms and insects when Beth discovers
Bridget it's too late to save her and
the group suddenly has another undead
family member to contend with
the family is generally able to stay
safe from Ellie after they trap her in
the hallway but she still makes attempts
to get back in from viciously banging
her head against the door to luring
Cassie into opening the door Ellie has
plenty of tricks up her sleeve to try
and get back into the room
do it for Mom and Dad
however it's not until Ellie hears
something in the vents the cat
introduced earlier in the film that she
successful Plan before you know it she's
seen hopping down from the vent in the
room that Beth is in to perform a sneak
attack on her meow
one of the important elements going into
the ending is the knowledge of just how
hard it is to kill a deadite to see if
she can learn a little more about how to
stop Ellie Beth decides to listen to the
records that came with the book
eventually she comes across a recording
of one of the priests talking about the
curse and how all the other priests have
become possessed he goes into detail
about his attempts to stop this demonic
force and kill his former friends but
pretty much says they all failed his
accounts give a chilling glimpse into
what the family is up against and
reaffirms what fans know from the
previous films prayer and religious
practices won't exercise the demon
burning burying or dismembering the
possessed ones aren't particularly
useful strategies either fans already
know from past films that deadites are
tough to kill but this recording paints
an even more horrifying picture for Beth
that solidifies their seemingly
unkillable nature
creates Terror through total chaos
after Ellie makes it back into the room
a huge brawl erupts that throws the
entire apartment into chaos Dany ends up
battling with Bridget in the kitchen
where she stabs him multiple times with
a knife Danny seems powerless to stop
Bridget until he's able to turn on the
stovetop and use a spray can to craft a
flamethrower that lights Bridget's head
on fire it doesn't kill her for good but
it's enough to at least keep her down
for a while as for Beth she ends up in a
gruesome fight with Ellie that spills
into the living room although Dany tries
to help he's quickly tossed aside by
Ellie who nearly has Beth in a prime
killing position however Cassie is able
to give Beth an edge when she slides her
mother's scissors over to Beth who uses
them to stab Ellie with the two deadites
incapacitated for the moment Beth is
ready to grab who's left and bolt for
the exit unfortunately she and Cassie
have to suffer the loss of Dany who
bleeds out from his wounds dany's guilt
over causing this curse to be Unleashed
was part of what fueled him to help stop
it and as we watch the film there's a
part of us that hopes he can find
Redemption sadly that isn't the case
making his end incredibly tragic and
Bittersweet his tearful apology to
Cassie right before he dies is
undeniably heartbreaking and it adds to
the cruelty of the moment dany's death
is one of the saddest moments of Evil
Dead rise and it makes Beth determined
to protect Cassie at all costs so she
doesn't lose another loved one
although Beth and Cassie are able to get
into the hallway they have a lot of
problems coming their way not only has
Ellie reawakened and begun pursuing them
again but all the people who have been
killed throughout the film are also
coming back as deadites
everybody here dies by Dawn that
as Beth and Cassie take their
blood-soaked elevator ride the book
suddenly flips through pages until it
lands on an image of a creature with
multiple bodies seemingly conjoined into
one disgusting looking entity that's
exactly what forms when Dany and
Bridget's bodies can join with their
mother and the ghoulish result is seen
when it attacks Beth and Cassie in the
garage this terrifying Abomination is
one of the film's most skin-crawling
inventions and is quite possibly the
most fearsome deadite of all time but
it's more than just a freaky monster at
the film's South by Southwest Premiere
director Lee Cronin spoke with Slash
film about the meaning behind this
Twisted creation and explained how it
went hand in hand with the distorted
lens the film puts on families he said
it's the worst version of family you can
imagine it's a story about this
subversion of perversion of family so
it's not just there to be creepy it also
has a little bit of meaning behind it
once Beth and Cassie make it into the
garage they honestly seem like they're
home free they have keys to a car just
waiting for them to drive out of there
and a pretty clear path ahead of him
however they're stopped by the arrival
of the newly formed deadite monster
forcing them to play a little hide and
seek as they try to head towards the
exit unfortunately the gate starts to
close as they make their way there and
they have to make a run for it which
gives away their location while Beth is
able to quickly slide under the closing
gate Cassie is grabbed by the creature
just before she makes it leading her to
be captured as a result Beth has to
smash open a nearby great to save Cassie
with no other option than to face the
deadite head-on Beth takes her shot at
killing it but it doesn't go as planned
the creature is simply too strong for
Beth to fight without a powerful enough
weapon and she's nearly turned to mulch
when the creature tries to shove her
into a wood chipper thankfully Cassie is
able to turn it off before that happens
and Beth turns the tables on the deadite
with the creature putting itself right
in front of the wood Chipper's opening
Beth grabs a nearby chainsaw and tells
Cassie to turn the chipper back on in
true Evil Dead fashion Beth revs up the
chainsaw and impales the creature
pushing it into the chipper the only
thing that's left once Beth is done is
Ellie's head which Beth proceeds to kick
into the wood chipper with this gesture
Evil Dead rise sticks to its franchise's
roots and delivers a gloriously bloody
finale that fans will Rave about
with the creature slain Beth and Cassie
are able to finally leave this nightmare
and start a new life their hearts are
certainly heavy since they've not only
had to go through this night of blood
and brutality but also because well most
of their family is now dead so that's a
bummer still they're happy to be alive
and will at least be able to welcome a
new member of the family since Beth
confirmed to Cassie that she's pregnant
maybe we'll see Beth and Cassie again in
a future film to help fight more
deadites possibly alongside Ash or Mia
from the 2013 remake but for now they're
simply going to start anew although
these two have gone through hellish
nightmares that'll follow them for the
rest of their lives they can rest easy
for now or can they
before the film begins to roll credits
we actually get one last scene that ties
back to the opening of the film a woman
named Jessica is talking with her friend
about the weekend they're going to have
together at the lake but soon sees all
the Carnage and blood spilling
throughout the garage then suddenly the
camera is shown zooming toward her at
different angles until she's left
screaming this ending ties back to the
opening where we see Jessica become
fully possessed and kill all of her
friends before rising out of the lake
ready to take on the rest of the world
with Jessica's fate now ambiguous and
her demonic power still growing it's
possible that this hints at a potential
sequel regardless it's a great end
Stinger that ties everything together
and shows how this kind of evil rarely
likes to stay dead
at the moment there have been no
announcements made about a sequel to
Evil Dead rise in development but signs
for one to come are very good reviews
for the film have been glowing and it is
poised to have a good run at the box
office however we have been in this
position before with Evil Dead prior to
this film's release plans for a sequel
to Army of Darkness the 2013 remake and
future seasons of Ash vs Evil Dead were
scrapped so just because Evil Dead rise
escaped that fate doesn't mean that it's
going to get follow-up films if it does
though there are plenty of good story
directions for future films to embrace
like this film a sequel could simply
follow new characters dealing with their
own evils derived from the Necronomicon
perhaps it could bring the worlds of all
three major films together and have its
Legacy characters team up to take on
Jessica who's now free to take her evil
elsewhere or we could simply see Beth
and Cassie try to escape this evil force
again after it comes to find them the
possibilities are endless for what
another Evil Dead movie could bring if
Evil Dead rise is a success it would be
groovy to see some of them come to life
foreign